he is the quarterback of a nine and two
team going for a tenth win against the
Atlanta Falcons this weekís Case Keenum
here in the Rich Eisen show how you
doing case doing well I am fine how how
are you walk
handling all the success that's
happening right now for you well it
could be a lot worse you know that it's
it's been good I've got I've got a good
team man we're we're enjoying this run
you know and we've got we got great
things still out of us so that's that's
what's cool about is about winning is
every game is big what that makes
everything you know the next game that
much bigger so we're going to go out and
you know just keep doing what we're
doing trust our process and you know
just take it a week at a time
what is the process what is it for you
okay so man it's it's do everything you
can each day that that you show up and
do everything you can to be the best
player you can be you know to give your
team the best chance to win and you know
obviously pretty good at night knowing
that I've done everything I can and then
I'll roll out there on Sundays and I
know that prepared my team is prepared
we're well coach well well prepared and
you know that we're confident in our and
our abilities and confident and they'll
be successful against whoever we're
playing are you the same quarterback as
you were when you were trying to get
these opportunities in previous spots
you know I'm the same but different I
mean I've I've always said that if
you're not getting better getting worse
so I I feel like I'm better somehow know
I'm better how so you know a million
different things that's what experience
that's what experience you know get you
you know that's why it's it's tough for
guys in this league that don't play to
get better and I've I've gotten to play
you know I think I've started over 30
games got some you know priceless
experience you know from my second year
on on up to now so I've you know I just
I just watched our last game again and
just graded myself out again and you
know things I'm gonna work on this week
to go out and beat the the Falcons so
where did you grade yourself poorly from
Thanksgiving you know there's some
better better pocket movement that I
could do some some better footwork you
know in the pocket that I can step up
trust my offensive line you know there's
always decision-making that that you
want back different different places you
want with the
of all that that you can do better you
know based on what the defense is giving
you so you know there's always there's
always stuff like that are know if
anybody ever plays a perfect game Case
Keenum joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show let's talk about the weight that
you had to get these opportunities what
was difficult about the weight case
seeing so many guys in the NFL who never
get an opportunity well what's so
difficult about that um you know there's
a lot of things I mean you know
obviously I was a I was a guy even
coming you know going back to high
school I wasn't very one very highly
recruited had one scholarship offer at
the University Houston and then you know
coming out of college wasn't sure what
the drafts would hold you know did the
combine did all that stuff and you know
felt good about having an opportunity at
least but but nobody called on draft day
was undrafted you know coach Kubiak with
the Texans gave me an opportunity there
and you know it was on the practice
squad in my first year you know so it's
just it's just a matter of taking with
thinking what you got and and doing the
best you can with it you know not not
feeling sorry for yourself not not
getting threw down because you know at
some point you're gonna get a shot it's
just about being ready when when that
time comes so I mean it's not as if you
weren't showing up and showing out in
Houston I mean you're still the all-time
leader in passing yards touchdowns in
completions so why why did what were you
being told about why you weren't getting
a call on draft day case yeah I don't
know um you know a lot of people may
have you know sought my heights was one
thing you know obviously we threw the
ball around a lot you know I don't know
if people thought maybe it was our
strength of schedule or who we were
playing or what but you know or being a
system guy I guess you know that was one
thing not that I've heard a lot you know
coming out was you know a product of a
system which i think is kind of silly
because every every offense out there is
some sort of system um you know you as a
quarterback me myself I try to fit
myself to whatever system I'm in and
that was that was the offense that we
ran and I was just trying to be the best
I can to be that's what I'm trying to do
now I'm I'm trying to be the best
quarterback for this offense that I can
then and interestingly enough as well as
you
been playing and showing up and showing
out we all in the national media are
waiting here Mike Zimmer say he's my guy
period end of story are you you know I
I'll be honest man I don't catch coach
Zimmer's press conferences I I don't I
don't I don't watch a lot of NFL Network
or any of that stuff
no there's not a second case but ok ok
good keep going what you're saying go
for it oh just just saying that a lot of
that stuff man there's there's a lot of
people's opinion out there and I'm not
saying coach Zimmer's opinion on matter
i'm saying like you know the media and
what happens there you know a lot of
that stuff is just kind of white noise
to me you know I come in I trust what my
coaches say and and and coach me up to
do and you know when it comes down to it
I want to I want this football team to
win and that you know that doesn't
matter you know what what my role is
what they say my role is whatever it is
I'm gonna come in and be the best
whatever it is they want me to be I'm
gonna come in and be the best that I can
be but the the conversation by the way
is that if you don't keep doing what
you're doing then Teddy Bridgewater
standing right there and he's the guy
that was drafted he was the guy who they
went to the playoffs whether your team
did before you were there and thus
that's the guy for the future you're not
you're not looking over your shoulder as
you play football case no I'm not
looking over my shoulder I know every
every time I go out there you gotta
prove yourself I mean every every time
you do a podcast or it's you got a you
got to prove yourself but there's I'm
sure there's a hundred people out there
behind you that you know that wants your
job to I mean are you looking over your
shoulder well I look over my shoulder I
see my show name you know what I mean
like I see it right there you know I
mean yeah I'm feeling it no you want
your job yes and you know they they're
doing everything they can to do that too
and so for me I know that there's a
there's a lot of people that you know
want to be one of the 32 so I don't take
it lightly you know I don't dwell on
that I don't think that makes me a
better football player by looking over
my shoulder so I just work on doing what
I can do and and being the best that I
can be and you know letting all that
stuff you know work work itself out Hey
look and it's neat we had feeling on the
show just last week or two weeks ago and
his story is amazing too I mean just
that what you guys have been doing Diggs
all of you guys you know Rudolph
obviously played for Notre Dame which
makes him
highfalutin being a Michigan guy but I
mean you know it just really is
remarkable what you guys are doing my
last question for you is do you feel
that special sense in that locker room
knowing that you could stay in that
locker room all the way to the very end
to the last game of the season with the
Super Bowl in their case yeah I mean I
think we all feel that we've got
something special going on you know I
think I think the guys on this on this
team I mean we all feel the same way you
know when it comes to to what's going on
I think I think - I think everybody's
smart enough to know that you know we
don't have time to you know sit here and
mess around with anything external
that's gonna gonna keep us from getting
where we want to go you know if I don't
know if that makes sense but we just we
don't we don't have we have we have too
much at stake to worry about anything
else so you know we're going to keep
doing our job we're gonna keep trust in
our process and that's what's that's
what's got us here and I think that
that's that's what will take us home
okay
well case just just know this you're
speaking to a member of the media who's
very you know we're all very
thin-skinned we have egos you just you
know don't don't say you don't watch I
got it on I got it on DVR okay and I and
I go through and I watch I watch every
every episode in the off season in the
off season okay all right so the day
after you pick the confetti out of your
hair in your home stadium is what you're
saying it's not what okay and I'll be
calling you and talking about how you're
doing and
question and asking me whether I had a
good enough broadcast to keep doing my
job that's what yes and then what were
you thinking taking that call from that
dude and what were you thinking on that
one I don't quite like the tables being
turned on me I understand
thanks case appreciate you calling I bet
that's Kasich in the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience